welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul and this video we're
breaking down the ending of pieces of a
woman on netflix
starring vanessa kirby the movie leaves
a lot of questions up in the air over
its last scene
and throughout this video we're going to
be giving an in-depth analysis on the
movie
so that you can hopefully understand it
better obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the film yet then i
highly recommend that you check out now
if you enjoy the video then please hit
the thumbs up button and make sure you
subscribe to the channel for breakdowns
like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into pieces of a
woman
okay so the movie primarily follows
martha and shawn
a couple that face an incredible tragedy
after their home birth ends with the
loss of their child
the film is full of grief and we watch
as martha becomes distant from not only
her family
but also her partner it's super super
depressing
but the film itself actually ends on a
hopeful note
when we see what is likely martha's
child climbing an apple tree
before she grabs one of the fruits
itself and bites into it
martha comes and collects her and we
bring focus to the tree before credits
start to roll
but what exactly is going on well i can
understand why you're confused
but this moment actually carries a lot
of symbolism with it
and on a second watch things become a
lot clearer
apples themselves carry a wealth of
meaning in the movie
and the fruit has been laced throughout
religion and the arts for millennia
they are often used as symbols of
knowledge and often when they're eaten
the person doing so can be seen as
gaining a new perspective on things that
change the perception of what's come
before
this is very much the case here and
throughout the film apples are a symbol
of martha's pain
grief and eventual acceptance of the way
things
are i feel like we need to give some
context to the events though before
diving into the hidden meaning
and thus i'll just be doing a quick plot
run down before we go further in depth
now the movie pretty much opens with
martha and shawn insisting on having a
home birth
and the original midwife that was
supposed to accompany them
is unfortunately another birth thus a
replacement named eva was sent out
and though things initially seemed to go
well we quickly saw that the child could
not breathe
eva tried to resuscitate it to no avail
and after an ambulance arrived we got a
massive time jump that saw the midwife
being put on trial for the child's death
it's an agonizing reveal especially
after the massive buildup that there is
at the start of the film
which features a half hour scene in
which we see martha going through all
the stages
of birth we learn that martha and sean's
relationship is in tatters
and it's clear that things aren't what
they used to be martha's relationship
with a family is also a breaking point
too
and it's clear that she's angry and
almost lost over the whole ordeal
at the testimony she blames eva but
after taking a step back and looking
over the photos of a child for the first
time
she returns to court to admit that the
midwife wasn't to blame
it's a major moment for the character
and it feels like a weight has been
lifted off everyone's shoulders after
they realize that she's accepted the
truth
she comes to terms with the loss and
spreads the child's ashes which
contradicts the idea that she was going
to donate the body to the university
this is when we get the next scene in
which we see the child luciana
climbing the apple tree before being
called in by martha
now there are different ways that you
can really take this and either the
child is real and she managed to have
another one
or it's simply a metaphor of a vet's
memory personally i tend to settle on
the former
and i think the hidden meaning which
we'll explore in just a bit
adds a lot of evidence towards this
taking things at face value though we
know that the child is called luciana
and it seems strange that this name
would be clearly said if it was simply a
version of a vet
thus we can gather that martha tried
again and had another child
showing that we must not give up even
when things look like they're at the
darkest
at one point in the film a character
discusses how time heals all wounds
and this is of course something that
many of us will experience firsthand
martha clearly came to terms with this
before the end of the film
and therefore i do take it that she was
able to move on from the experience
and try once more second chances are
always available
and i'm not just talking in terms of
giving birth but there are other options
such as fostering and adoption
which also could have happened i know
that a lot of people likely believe that
sean is still in the picture
but the fact that he's not does hint to
me that he did indeed leave
he was offered money by the family to go
and seem to accept that seattle was
where his feature lay
the last time we saw him he was being
dropped off at the airport
and therefore i take the ending as
meaning that martha is likely with
someone new
who has given her the space she needed
which sean could not
he leaves his beanie behind for
something to remember him by
and therefore i think that martha is
either with somebody else
or that she's raising the child on her
own after adopting it
now the deeper meaning which builds upon
this idea is that the apples exist as a
symbol of martha's mind state
and this is showcased throughout the
movie during the trial
martha states that her babies smell like
an apple and therefore we can put some
importance in their meaning
after the death of a vet we get a time
jump which sees martha putting on a
brave face for the world
shortly after she comes across a young
girl and seems to be happy
but this illusion is quickly broken by
the memory of her child
which is brought on by her own body the
character continues to a fruit shop
and we can see her browsing the apples
there
martha takes her time looks over them
for quite a while and picks out the
perfect one before she comes face to
face with a friend of her mother's
we later learned that martha suspected
that something else was going on in this
conversation
and that she tried to appear happy thus
her spending time picking out an apple
that appears perfect
represents how she very much cares about
her image
and the way that things look martha is
clearly struggling and going through a
lot of trauma
but she knows that it will cause issues
if she doesn't appear to be fine
and thus who's spending the time to make
sure that everything around her looks
and damaged
is very significant later she eats an
apple that's already started to rot
and this very much represents how i view
her relationship with sean
it started to decay in and though she's
still trying to keep it with her through
the act of consumption
it's not as sweet as it used to be and
potentially not even worth going through
now on a more positive note we catches
spitting out apple seeds
and seeds themselves come to represent a
number of things
seeds carry the idea of rebirth and in
order to get to one
you have to basically consume an apple
take away everything from it until
all that remains is this single thing in
which new life can grow
seeds are very much symbolic of her
planting something new
and along with this taking a new path so
this collecting of the seeds represents
how she's starting to put things in
place mentally
in order to grow though this doesn't
happen initially
after finally seeing the photographs of
a vet and accepting that eva wasn't
responsible
they finally start to sprout this of
course shows that she's now willing to
move on
and we also catch her spreading the
ashes meaning that she's finally let go
cut to luciana climbing this enormous
apple tree and personally i believe that
this is what sprouted from the seeds
that martha was collecting
due to the size of it we know that
several years have likely passed
and thus this explains why a child of
this age is able to appear in the scene
the tree stands as a way to remember a
vet and is a monument that luciana can
now climb
and eat the fruit of it shows that even
when things seem like they are at the
darkest
it is possible to break it all down come
to grips with it
and from there grow which definitely
feels like the journey that martha went
on throughout the film
so overall i think that martha has
managed to move on
and accept what happened to a vet and
this has allowed her to have a new child
though her first one will never be
forgotten now before we get into the
review part of the video
i just want to let you know we're giving
away three copies of the hobbit and lord
of the rings 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video subscribe
to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the film in
the comments section below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of january and the set will
be shipped out from then whoever gets
the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part now as for my thoughts
i i'd say i enjoyed the film as a whole
in the aftermath of it
even though i didn't enjoy it at the
time now
what do i mean by that well pieces of a
woman is
very depressing and it feels almost
unbearable at points
as we go through it there's very little
positivity in this movie
but i think that's what we needed to
sync to these depths so that the ending
was so
uplifting the performances are
incredible here and you can see why
vanessa kirby is already winning awards
because of her betrayal
i do feel a bit wrong scoring this uh
as it's a bit of a sensitive matter and
i think people who've experienced
something like this in their own life
will find it easy to relate to whereas
others won't so it's not something that
you can
exactly assign a number to now because
of that this movie won't be for everyone
and i think you'll already know whether
it's for you or not
it's very harrowing but i think it works
well with the topics and themes that it
touches upon
and handles them in a very profound way
i know i'll be going back to it ever
again but
i have to say that's probably because
it's going to stick with me for some
time
i definitely recommend that you watch it
and make up your own mind as i know a
lot of people will take different things
from it
and have their own perspective it's out
now on netflix
and i'd of course love to hear your
thoughts on it as i'm sure there's a lot
to talk about
in terms of the deeper meaning and the
movie itself now obviously leave them
below and if you enjoy this video then
please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the ending of kobrakai
season 3 which will be linked on screen
right now
the links to our socials are also in the
description and if you want to support
the channel
there's a join button there that that
massively helps us out
anyway if not then thank you for sitting
through the video
i hope this hasn't ruined your weekend
i've been paul
you've been the best and take care
yourself mate peace